as the 2020 Democrat presidential
primary heats up one issue above all
takes center stage B s yes BS artists
descend on Iowa and New Hampshire to
spread heaps of cow dung ironically
often about heaps of cow dung we will
analyze BS from the campaign trail to
the mainstream media all of this and
more check it out I'm Michael Knowles
this is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
this is an important question there is a
philosophical text that people don't
read as much anymore it came out I think
about 20 years ago called on BS by Harry
G Frankfurt who's a philosopher from
Princeton and I got to tell you watching
the arocs wall well presidential
announcement video watching Pete but a
googa googa try to pick a fight with
Mike Pence watching all of the crazy me
two attacks on Joe Biden it just occurs
to me that this campaign is about BS we
will analyze exactly what BS means and
why this campaign seems to be about
nothing or actually specifically about
BS but first there's a lot of things in
life that aren't right carpet in showers
eating dip with your fingers paying too
much money for your cell phone bill all
things are not right that's not right
thanks to mint mobile you don't have to
overpay for wireless anymore with mint
mobile you can cut your wireless bill
down to just 15 bucks a month
they've reimagined Wireless making it
easy and to online only which means they
can pass significant savings directly to
you you can save thousands of dollars a
year using mint mobile without
sacrificing quality service mint mobile
makes it easy to cut your wireless bill
down to just 15 bucks a month use your
own phone and any mint mobile plan you
can keep your old number along with all
your existing contacts with mint mobile
choose between plans with eight three
twelve gigabytes of LTE 4G data and stop
paying for unlimited data that you'll
never use every plan comes with
unlimited nationwide talking text if
you're not 100% satisfied mint mobile
has you covered with their seven day
money-back guarantee ditch your old
wireless bill and start saving with mint
mobile to get your new wireless plan for
just fifteen bucks a month get the plan
shipped to your door for free go to mint
mobile comm slash Knowles Canada wles
that's mint mobile comm slash Knowles
kn-know wles cut your wireless bill to
fifteen bucks a month and get free
shipping on your mint mobile plan at
mint mobile.com slash Knowles BS
so there's this book that came out about
20 years ago on BS by Harry G Frankfurt
and what he pointed out is that one of
the most salient features of our culture
is that there is so much B s quote
everyone knows this each of us
contributes his share so you see it all
of around you now perhaps the reason for
that is not that people are biessing
more than they used to but because we're
communicating so much more than we used
to so now obviously you're watching this
on the internet or you're listening to
it in your car or on your phone or
wherever ooh everybody is talking to
everybody this is a product of the
Internet age okay maybe the percentage
of BS remains the same even the volume
has greatly increased but as Harry
Frankfurt points out quote in
consequence we have no clear
understanding of what BS is why there is
so much of it or what function it serves
and we lack a conscientiously developed
appreciation of what it means to us in
other words we have no theory and
coincidentally I was watching all these
Democrat presidential candidates coming
out and not only are they biessing
they're even using the word BS quite a
lot here is who Leon Castro but I don't
think I think it's I think it's bull to
say that oh that we're just gonna you
know no I think it's bull to say that no
people can get away with laughing you
know I think that that's completely the
wrong way to look at it I really love I
love Bill Maher here goes oh oh you said
BS oh you said that's how you know
they're super serious by the way is when
the candidates swear on the campaign
trail that's how you know they're very
serious but who Leon Castro is not the
only person who is using the word BS on
the trail you've got this new guy this
congressman from California Eric's wall
well he puts up his announcement video
his campaign ad and in that ad he uses
the word BS as well Donald Trump was
bold but a lot of what he was bold about
was just boring that's what it is
it was just BS bs according to this book
on BS quote is not fundamentally that
the speaker regards his statements as
false
so it's
not that BS is when you just
intentionally lie and it's just obvious
lies and if that's that's not really
what defines BS what defines BS instead
is that the BS r intends the BS
statements to convey a certain
impression of himself so when you BS
it's not that you're intentionally lying
i guess you could be lying or that
you're telling the truth or that you're
saying it's actually that you don't
really have any regard for what you're
saying at all you don't really have any
regard for the truth value of what
you're saying you don't really have any
regard for the object of what you're
saying all you are really concerned with
is how you are being perceived what
impression you are giving of yourself so
when guys like who Leon Castro or Eric's
wall well when they even used the word
bs they are just trying to give an
impression of themselves yeah I'm gonna
talk tough yeah I'm gonna speak casually
yeah I can use profanity that is but
it's not actually conveying an idea or
an idea about which they really care
this is obviously what's going on in the
twenty twenty Democrat primary this is
what Pete but ago gagas attack on Mike
Pence is all about we talked about this
yesterday Pete but a gagaga went out and
he's the mayor of South Bend Indiana
he's gay and he came out and he said I
want the Mike Pence's of the world to
know that if you have a problem with Who
I am
you have a problem with my creator he
goes out unprompted and says Mike Pence
has a false faith Mike Pence's violating
the commands of God he's insulting God
now what did Mike Pence do to deserve
that nothing Mike Pence has never
criticized Pete Boettiger
Mike Pence has never attacked Pete buddy
go go go sexuality actually there we
only know of two instances where Mike
Pence ever referred to Pete buddy go
gaga one when Pete buddy Gaga got
deployed to Afghanistan the Navy
Reserves pence called him and wished him
well and then a second time actually was
when Pete Buddy gugga declared himself a
gay came out of the closet publicly and
Pence was asked about this and what did
pence say did he attack his sexuality
did he launched a homophobic tirade no
he said quote I hold mayor buddy gagaga
in the highest personal regard I see him
as a dedicated public servant and a
patriot so actually the only time that
pens has ever spoken publicly about Pete
Buddy gagaga was to give him a
compliment so then why just Pete buddy
gugga go out and go after pence because
of BS so he's saying Pence has a problem
with me Pence has a false faith of false
religion he's why is he going it doesn't
matter if any of those claims are true
doesn't matter that Pence has never
attacked but a Gurkha it's that Pete but
a gugga gun needs to be perceived as a
victim and so he's got a BS it's all
just about how he can portray himself
how he can make himself be perceived by
people Pete but agog Agha is white he's
a male he's Ivy league-educated he went
to Harvard he was in the military he's a
Rhodes Scholar he is an elite guy is a
young mayor so it's very hard for him to
portray himself as a victim he has to
invent false enemies he has to tilt at
windmills he has to be s going back to
that other guy the guy in California
who's now running for president for some
reason who knows why Erick's whoa well
here is just a clip you should watch the
whole announcement for a master class in
BS but here is just a little clip of him
introducing himself to the American
people you tell him you can't do
something he's gonna do it today we are
just governing crisis to crisis you know
I'm from the first generation that might
do worse than our parents we can't do
nothing we
- in this country go big is on the
issues we take on most Americans believe
we need to have coverage for all when it
comes to health be bold in the solutions
we offer most Americans believe that to
be free of gun violence I went to the
funeral for four police officers range
to take the most dangerous weapons out
of the hands the most dangerous and do
good in the way that we govern and most
Americans agree that to address climate
chaos to make sure your house doesn't
end up underwater or on fire we should
do something about it but make sure that
we're not pitting workers against their
job the economy is not the unemployment
rate Donald Trump was bold but a lot of
what he was bold about was just bull and
the economy is not the stock
if you the economy is you we need to do
better not worse we need to be strong
not weak we need to we need to we need
to this is BS from the beginning this
guy is a total BS sir this guy Eric SWA
well here's his entire resume here's his
entire career he went to college at
Campbell University in North Carolina so
I'm going back all the way until he was
18 he then transfers to the University
of Maryland
he then studies politics okay well he's
there he's on the student government so
he's a student politician not just a
student politician he is the student
liaison to the City Council of College
Park at UMD he sticks around a UMD for
law school okay now he's he's got a
couple internships in there
what was he in turn for is it a private
business as if no no it's for a
congressman in California's 10th
district then after law school he goes
and works as the Alameda County Deputy
District Attorney so it goes straight
into politics there then he's on the
Dublin heritage and Cultural Arts
Commission so a political appointment
then he's on the Dublin Planning
Commission another political appointment
then he's on the Dublin City Council
local politician then he runs for
Congress and wins from California's 15
congressional district this guy since
the age of 18 has done nothing but work
in government work in politics run for
office that's all he's done in his
entire life
this guy is B it's like if on house of
cards
if there were a campaign ad for the
Challenger candidate and it's so
exaggerated it's so hyperbolic it would
be Eric's wall wells announcement he
even said by the way as I find sort of
distasteful
he said the September 11th terrorist
attacks occurred during his internship
on Capitol Hill and that inspired him to
public service so he's trying to link
his own career ambitions to
9:11 if 9/11 inspired you to service you
would have joined the military you were
exactly military age at that time what
was he 19 years old or something
18 years old but it didn't and actually
it obviously didn't inspire him to
public service he already got the
political internship he was already
working on Capitol Hill pure example of
BS you're gonna see a lot of this he's
gonna say things like listen climate
chaos climate chaos is a big deal that's
the new phrase I guess they use it's
it's better than climate change or
global warming because whenever the the
people understand what you mean by
climate alarmism
whichever euphemism you're using they
start to hate it so they always have to
change the euphemism so now they're on
climate chaos if you don't want your
house to get set on fire then we've got
a I don't know what tax people at a 90
percent tax rate or spend ninety three
trillion dollars on the green New Deal
what do you have to do look Eric's well
well won't tell you specifics he just
has to talk out of both sides of his
mouth we need to stop climate chaos we
need to make sure workers have their
jobs we need to do good that's actually
his slogan do good it's like okay what
is the least objectionable campaign
slogan we could have do good okay that's
yeah that's uh that's testing pretty
well okay good that's focus group
testing very well do good since the
economy isn't GDP or the unemployment
rate actually sort of it is being the
economy is you you total BS now he's the
youngest he's been newest BSR in this
race you'll notice in that whole
announcement he doesn't talk about
anything specifically he doesn't make
one detailed policy proposal you know
there's that guy on the Internet Andrew
yang he's this crazy futurist meme guy
and he's sort of a joke candidate at
least that guy has policy proposals at
least a candidate actually will give you
a specific proposal for any number of
policies be essers don't do that
BSR is just talking these broad terms
and out of both sides of their mouths
he's the youngest in the race the oldest
BSR in the race is Joe Biden and look
Joe Biden
actually his BS has gotten him into
trouble here because all he really cares
about is being perceived as this nice
empathetic guy that's why he smells
people's hair and Pat's them on the
shoulder and gives them massages and
holds their hand and nuzzles them is
because he doesn't care about anything
specific he doesn't really care about
the truth value of what he's saying he
just wants to be perceived well well now
that's coming back and hitting him
there's a new accusation against Joe
Biden this from a young woman named
Lilly J Lilly J talks about how she met
Joe Biden at some event and she doesn't
know how to feel about it I'll let her
say her piece then we'll explain why she
doesn't know what to say about it she
says quote I introduced Biden as an ally
when he came to the stage he leaned in
and gave me coffee scented words of
encouragement then he held my hand and
pointed at me as he said something to
the crowd holding hands with the vice
president felt a little odd when was the
last time I had held hands with anyone
but I didn't experience it as intrusive
or unsettling I remember later being
disappointed that most of the press
pictures of me that day captured some
degree of physical contact with either
the vice president or president I could
have sworn there was a moment I stood on
my own all right I have to pause there
for just one second she was surprised
that the newspapers included photos of
her standing with the leader of the free
world instead of by herself it can you
imagine the ego the pride the hubris the
arrogance to say you have a photo taken
with the president of the United States
you have another photo taken just sort
of smiling on your own and you want the
newspapers to run the one of just you
why does the president have to be in my
photo
that's the hubris that's the pride that
these people are talking about she goes
on mostly I tried not to think about my
day at the White House at all it was
meant to be lemonade from lemons a
capstone to an experience I would sooner
forget why hadn't I been more aware of
Biden's contact with me
why didn't
occur to me to be perturbed this is it
this sums it all up why didn't it occur
to me to be perturbed
she wasn't perturbed she met the
President and the Vice President of the
United States and they were nice to her
and they spoke to her and they said nice
things to her and that was a good day
but now in retrospect she realizes she
could have gotten a lot more currency if
she had pretended to be a victim if she
could have pretended to be aggrieved
this is the great new privilege this is
this is the new currency this is the BS
because what what she was focusing on
then was the actual interaction the
interaction itself which is the vice
president's talking to me is saying nice
things to me this is really nice okay
thank you very much now she's thinking
oh hold on in this new environment I
could be perceived as a victim even
though I'm not sure that I'm a victim I
don't doesn't sound like I'm a victim
there's no evidence that I'm a victim at
all but now because I met the vice
president and he touched my hand
now I can get another 15 minutes of fame
now I can be perceived as aggrieved and
important and have social currency all
bs and yet despite all of that Joe Biden
is still at the top of the field of the
2020 race according to morning consult
Joe Biden is polling at 32% right now
even with all of the weird touchy gropey
things he's only lost one percentage
point in the polls over the past week
Bernie Sanders is number two right now
but he's number two with 23% support so
Biden is up nine points on Bernie
Sanders right now that is a pretty good
lead obviously a lot of it at this early
date is still name recognition Joe Biden
was the vice president if Barack Obama
comes out for him hard early on and
perhaps he could translate that into
really maintaining a lead in this race
though I'm not so sure what we do know
for sure though is that of all of these
candidates of all of the issues the only
thing that unifies them is they are all
simply about perception
and in particular about being perceived
as a victim
being perceived as empathetic being
perceived as likable
this is true of Elizabeth Warren her
central issue is trying to say that
being one one-thousandth Native American
makes her a victimized minority Erichs
wall well just all about being perceived
just he's the he's the guy he's the
straight shooter
he's the hey he's reasonable hey come on
guys no snow policy proposal in that
whole Rick bado of work the same thing
Joe Biden the same thing I'm Allah
Harris Pete buddy gagaga all of them the
entire issue is about being perceived as
a victim the question now for Democrats
is can they win on that can they win on
just appearing empathetic whether it's
the kind of slick old walking simper
smiley Joe empathy or whether it's the
aggrieved minority of empathy like Pete
buddy gagaga or Liz Warren or Kamala
Harris or whomever can you win just on
that or do you have to offer a specific
solution to a specific problem this is
actually going to see the real
litigation of how Trump won because
there was a big debate that broke out
after 2016 did Trump win because he ran
on a mood because he ran on an attitude
because he was just talked tough and
said the right words that's what a lot
of people think that's what the never
Trump pers think that's what the
anti-trump left thinks that's even what
a lot of conservatives think or did
Donald Trump win because he offered
specific policy solutions that were
different from what his Republican
opponents offered he talked about
raising barriers to trade
this was an athame to Republican Dogma
he talked about building a gigantic wall
and cutting off immigration anathema to
Chamber of Commerce Republican Dogma he
spoke in brutal terms about very
specific problems in many ways the 2020
race could show us which that was
I tend to favor and cultures argument I
tend to think that the American people
are not just gullible idiots I think
they actually vote for specific reasons
they know what they're talking about and
Donald Trump was offering them something
that was different from what a lot of
other people were and so they gravitated
toward him
I actually think talking to a lot of
people all throughout the country I mean
how many states have I been to in the
last year just on this young America's
Foundation speaking tour I have been all
over to just about every part of this
country and when I talk to people and I
talked to Trump supporters I find that
it's not that they're cheering on when
Donald Trump is really mean or vicious
or cruel actually most of them say he's
doing good things and his personality is
a little out there and he's a little too
brash but I still like him anyway they
liked him in spite of his personality
excesses not because of them
this comes as news to elites on the
coasts on both parties for that matter
but it just seems to me that eventually
you might get through the Democrat
primary you might get through a certain
point you have to offer something
concrete even Barack Obama who was the
hopi changey vague candidate even he
sort of offered something concrete in so
much as he was the guy who voted against
the Iraq war Hillary Clinton voted for
the Iraq war he differentiated himself
by saying I voted against the Iraq war
that was something specific and I think
a lot of people gravitated toward that
especially in the Democrat Party
you can't just rely on fake ly messaging
forever eventually reality reasserts
itself but fake ly messaging can get you
around for a while this is again an a
prime example of BS this time from the
mainstream media there was a poll that
was just conducted by NBC Wall Street
Journal tax times coming around you
maybe are looking at your refund right
now trying to figure out what you're
gonna pay what you know how many of you
believe that you will get a bigger tax
refund this year than you did last year
how many of you believe that you will
get you will save money on your taxes
this year compared to
last year NBC News Wall Street Journal
asked that question only 17% of
Americans believe that their taxes will
go down 28% of Americans believe that
they will pay more in taxes
27% say that they will pay the same 28%
say they don't know enough to say only
17% believe that their taxes will
decrease because of that tax bill last
year this is reflected in public
approval of the tax bill according to
Pew Research last month just 36 percent
approve of the tax cut forty-nine
percent disapprove of the tax cut just
one third of Republicans believe that
they're getting a tax cut 10% of
independents believe it 7 percent of
Democrats believe it even among hardcore
Trump supporters 36 percent believe that
they are getting a tax cut another 36%
say that they're staying the same and 6%
said they're paying more
even among hardcore Trump supporters
what is the reality there was an
analysis done by the Tax Policy Center
Tax Policy Center is nonpartisan it
showed that 80 percent of Americans will
receive a tax cut under the 2018 tax law
80 percent of Americans will see their
taxes decrease and yet only 17 percent
of Americans think that their taxes will
decrease that is the power of the
mainstream media that is the power of BS
that is the power of demagogue
politicians who went out from day one
and they said it's a tax scam before the
tax bill was even released it said it's
a tax scam it's a tax hike they don't
care about the truth value of that
statement they would have said the
statement regardless of what the tax
bill said what they were positioning
themselves as is we oppose Trump Trump
bad we good
therefore what Trump does is bad and
therefore the tax bill is bad therefore
the tax bill is going to raise your
taxes and then you saw this breathless
reported throughout the mainstream media
for months and months and months and
then you're now seeing the effect of
that even as Tax Day rolls around now
there is a little issue with BS is that
you can always pull some random
statistics to try to buttress your claim
and then people who are uninterested in
truth will just endlessly recite those
so you can point out now tax refunds are
actually down six billion dollars this
year so there are six billion dollars
less in refunds this year however the
reason for that is that people are
getting more than their take-home pay
people actually are getting more in each
paycheck a lot of people have direct
deposit a lot of people don't notice
that they're getting more in each
paycheck wasn't a ton more but it's a
little bit more also it's because the
very wealthy are depending on where you
live especially in coastal cities
especially in blue states their taxes
are actually not decreasing in some
cases they're increasing nevertheless
the reality remains the vast vast
majority of Americans get a tax cut Matt
Iglesias that left-wing writer for
voxcom he came out and said a lot of
people don't want to take credit for
messaging victories like this but fewer
than one in five Americans thinks
they're getting a tax cut even though
objectively the vast majority of
Americans are he was bragging about this
he was bragging about BS for a whole
year and it worked
the question of the 2020 race is how
long can this work for how long before
someone punctures in is there gonna be a
real candidate a forceful candidate in
the race who punctures all of that BS
we'll have to find out now speaking of
the mainstream media as I'm assuming you
weren't watching this week on ABC but
they're talking about Donald Trump's new
appointments Donald Trump is appointing
new people there was a big gutting of
the Department of Homeland Security
yesterday and he's been talking about
adding Herman Cain to the federal
reserve board this is a prime example of
what the mainstream media does this is
how they convinced you that the tax cut
was actually a tax hike this is how they
convince you of all of their lives but
the way they do it
is they go on television they have a
nice tie they put on their jacket they
speak were the really super serious
voice and they say things that aren't
true we'll get to that in one second but
first I've got to say goodbye to
Facebook and YouTube go over to daily
wire calm 10 bucks a month $100 for an
annual membership you get me you get the
end reply even sure you get the Ben
Shapiro show you get the mount wall show
you get to test questions in the mailbag
you get to ask questions backstage you
get another Kingdom most importantly you
get the leftist ears tumblr mmm oh
that's really good yeah that oh that's
really good you know it's a very subtle
taste today it tastes like nothing it
tastes like the subtle non-existent
issues of the 2020 Democrat presidential
primary but sometimes that's kind of
nice you don't what you want a nice you
just to play on the taste buds you don't
want it to overpower you go get your
leftist to your tumblr daily wire.com
we'll be right back
here is Yvette Simpson
who works for democracy for America some
left-wing group she's on ABC reacting to
the report that President Trump may
appoint former presidential candidate
Herman Cain to the Federal Reserve Board
I think at this time it's more important
to make sure that appointments are you
know are validated or Herman Cain I just
want to leave it there Herman Cain today
actually I worked for a candidate who
ran in a primary against Herman Cain
yeah the the question is not in my mind
Herman Cain's qualifications he actually
has been at a Federal Reserve Bank I
think he understands these issues the
question is around the independence of
the Federal Reserve ok so then they
pivot a little bit we're very lucky here
the reason we got this clip is because
Lonnie Chen of the Hoover Institution
who used to work for Mitt Romney he
happened to be on this panel and he just
couldn't let that egregious lied go the
entire mainstream media have been
talking now for weeks but how crazy it
would be to appoint Herman Cain to the
Federal Reserve Board why on earth would
you ever appoint Herman Cain
the 999 guy that wacky presidential
candidate Herman Cain Herman Cain is a
very accomplished man he was the CEO of
Godfather pizza that's pretty impressive
also he was already on a Federal Reserve
Bank board Herman Cain served on a
Federal Reserve Board before he is
eminently qualified for this he
obviously would be a good person and so
this woman Yvette Simpson say okay well
never but they just it's just this
posturing they say oh look I'm not even
gonna answer this question I'm not even
going to answer how crazy it would be to
have Herman Cain on the Herman Cain the
Federal Reserve I'm just gonna leave it
there it's just this innuendo it's just
this perception but here let me make the
argument for Herman Cain's
qualifications he's already been on a
Federal Reserve Board okay that seems
okay that seems to refute your argument
then more innuendo more insinuation well
the combination of the denomination
potential nomination of Stephen Moore
and Herman
Kame I mean Lonnie would probably have
freshmen students in their economics
class that are more qualified than
Stephen Moore and Herman came to be in
those positions are the freshmen in the
economics classes have they been the CEO
of a major corporation have those
freshmen in the economics classes been
on Federal Reserve boards no but it's
just this attitude it's just this
posture and so they're all of these 20
20 candidates for sure are running on
posture they're all running on attitude
is that enough you know we've seen
certain races have been about mostly
nothing certain presidential races have
been very consequential very much about
issues so when you look at say the 2000
presidential race Bush versus Gore that
race was basically about nothing we had
just won the Cold War we had this
massive economic boom which was given to
us by Reaganomics and by the information
age by the the tech explosion we had
relative peace abroad relative peace at
home so the campaign was basically about
nothing what was the major issue of that
campaign the main one that I can
remember is George Bush saying we must
restore honor and dignity to the White
House because Bill Clinton got a little
frisky in the Oval Office and that was
basically the biggest issue of the
campaign is that Bill Clinton got frisky
in the Oval Office with his intern not
about a whole lot fast forward to 2008
2008 was about a lot it was a referendum
about the Iraq war and it was a
referendum on the financial crisis on
the housing crisis
maybe those issues were debated unfairly
but they really were about real issues
2016 was about real issues you had just
finished eight years of Barack Obama the
slowest recovery we had ever seen in the
country a corseting of race relations at
divisiveness that slowly took course you
saw a guy who was elected because he was
supposed to get us out of wars in the
Middle East we actually began more wars
in the
least under him you had a demoralization
of the left and you had a lot of
righteous anger on the right you had a
guy who weaponized the IRS against his
political opponents weaponized the DOJ
against his political opponents we're
now learning he weaponized the DOJ and
the FBI to spy on the Republican
presidential candidate who would come
after him you had this massive
corruption you had a total disruption of
the entire health care sector one-sixth
of the economy being taken over a
president who told you if you like your
doctor you can keep your doctor and then
whoops you can't keep your doctor a
president have told you the new health
care system it's not gonna cost anything
and then when it costs a ton of money
when the rate of increase increased when
premiums shot through the roof
he said well you didn't think you were
gonna get all that free stuff for
nothing did you you don't think that
free stuff was gonna be free did you and
you had a lot of pent-up righteous anger
about real issues previously you'd had
the tea party movement then you had I
guess what you would call the Trump
movement in 2016 that was a campaign
about issues but now things are going
pretty well again so now I when I look
at the political scene I'm sort of
reverting back to the 90s I see immense
economic prosperity where we have very
high employment record high employment
right now record low unemployment and
record low unemployment specifically
among groups that have typically have
higher unemployment like black Americans
and Hispanics you're seeing people get
to keep more of their money tax
decreases relative peace abroad drawing
down from conflicts overseas you're
seeing a restoration of judicial
restraint at the federal courts at the
Supreme Court
overall things are going pretty well
even on on issues that could be real
hobbyhorses for the left like
environmentalism you're seeing massive
environmental advancement the United
States is leading the world in reducing
carbon emissions and taking care of the
natural environment we're doing better
than all of the people in the Paris
climate Accord it actually upholding
those values things are going relatively
terrific I sound like drew Clavin like
things are going tickety-boo
and so I think that environment of
prosperity that that equitable just
environment that we're looking at opens
the door again to BS to just attitudes
to just puff to just posturing but can
that take them over the finish line I
don't see how it does
I don't so where where does that where
does that end for them what what voter
in Michigan
what voter in Wisconsin what voter in
Pennsylvania what voter in Florida who
has seen the country improve is is going
to flip because Pete buddy Giga invented
some victimhood because Pete but a guy
Gaga imagines that somebody doesn't like
him for his sexual preferences because
Cory Booker's crying tears of rage
because why would anybody flip that vote
I just don't see it it just seems a
little thin
it just seems also because things are
improving so one one of the the lines
one of the the kind of insinuations here
is that because there's turnover in the
Trump administration things are getting
worse I mean Herman Cain in the Federal
Reserve I mean I mean I'm just gonna
leave it there okay I'm just gonna leave
it there that seems like you're getting
a guy who's qualified and experienced to
take over a job that sounds good all of
the replacements seem to have been
pretty good Mike Pompeo is doing a great
job john bolton is doing a great job
from everything we can tell Mick
Mulvaney is doing a good job is the
acting chief of staff from what we could
tell john kelly did a better job than
Ryan's brevis Sarah Sanders did a better
job than Sean Spicer things have been
improving and now the DHS secretary has
been canned and there is now an acting
DHS secretary and we'll see who the the
permanent replacement is seems like an
improvement the it seems like it could
really only be an improvement because
the crisis that the border has not
abated it's actually gotten worse their
reports coming in now that we're getting
a hundred thousand people entering this
country illegally every 30 days so we're
going
over 3,000 people a day one of the
relative record numbers that came out
last month was 2500 a day and that was
considered outrageous just a few months
ago it was only a thousand a day which
is still very high hundred thousand in a
month is a huge number so what does
President Trump say he sees that the
person doing the job is not doing it
well enough so he cans them and replaces
them and hopefully they start to do it
better
again there the attitude the insinuation
the BS is going to say because of all
that turnover it's chaos it isn't
working you've got to vote for us in
reality it seems to me those voters are
going to take the exact opposite
impression say Oh things are improving
okay good Oh finally once all the BS
clears once the mainstream media clears
they're gonna look at their bank
accounts they're gonna look at their
paychecks and say oh yeah I'm making a
little bit more money now that's a good
thing that's a good thing before we go I
do have to get to this in our remaining
minutes I have been saying it for years
finally a radio host named Rick Wiles is
he's finally coming out and buttressing
what we've all been thinking look for
how many millennia now have we been
waiting for the Antichrist to come and
you guys didn't realize he was right
under your own nose the whole time
our very own Ben Shapiro Ben Shapiro
denies the deity of Jesus Christ I've
heard him say this before that's right
what I'm shocked by is that there are
millions of conservatives in this
country including Christians who support
him yeah go gaga over him yes they'll
buy his books those buy those little you
know those just his career and yet he
openly denies that Jesus Christ is a son
of God that makes him an antichrist yes
right st. John said that anybody who
denies that Jesus Christ came to earth
as God in human flesh is Antichrist yes
there is no one Antichrist there is a
spirit of Antichrist and ben shapiro has
the spirit of Antichrist because he
denies that jesus christ is the son of
god
he denied said he's resurrected he said
we don't even use that word resurrected
alright he he's a caballes he laughed
when he said prophet he mocked a prophet
called him a rebel rebel criminals why
why are any of you out there following
Ben Shapiro why you're schizophrenic yes
you're spiritually schizophrenic you got
to cut off this stuff but the money's
flowing to people like Ben Shapiro right
and the doors are opening for him
because he denies Christ I love this
last argument at the end he says he
begins he says why are you giving your
money to Ben Shapiro the implication
being you're not giving your money to my
program then at the end he says the
money's flowing they just keep giving
the money to Ben Shapiro which is a
terrible thing because you should be
giving your money to me I agree I think
people should be giving all of their
money to the Michael and old show I mean
the fact that they give it to the Ben
Shapiro show although the very fact that
I have a show does bring up a little
problem with Rick while this argument
here because if if Ben Shapiro is the
Antichrist it does occur to me he's like
the worst Antichrist ever he could not
be worse at being the Antichrist he
because Ben has a network called The
Daily wire and there are five hosts on
that network there is Ben then there's
drew then there's me then there's Matt
Walsh and then there is Jeremy boring
the God came hosts the backstage show so
there are five hosts on Ben Shapiro's
Network and so this guy definitely wursy
Amica definitely I don't see him at
church on Sundays but then this guy is
an outspoken Anglican I am an outspoken
Catholic Matt Walsh is an outspoken
Catholic and Jeremy boring is an
outspoken antinomian I don't even know
what you'd call his theology
fundamentalism something I don't know at
least he would call it Christianity he
believes in Jesus so one of the guys who
owns the daily wire if ago he was
running
right down the hall hosts a show he's a
quite Christian four out of five of the
daily wire hosts are outspoken
Christians but wait a second me now I'm
seeing it because if a guy were the
Antichrist and he didn't want you to
know that he was the Antichrist what is
the most Antichrist II thing he would
have done he'd hire a bunch of
Christians to spread their views and
faiths and beliefs and message on his
airwaves that would be that subtle
little serpent that's what he would do
he would hire all these Christians and
then they would get to talk about their
faith on the air all the time every
single day and then that is how he would
affect his Antichrist agenda the only
rebuttal I could imagine to that is that
a house divided against itself cannot
stand
and that the devil can't cast out demons
who said that was that is it the
Antichrist who said that or was it
somebody else it was another Jewish guy
said I think all right I had to bring it
up because I regularly refer to Ben as
the Antichrist but then when I started
thinking about the argument when I
started thinking when Rick Wiles the
radio host really spelled it out for me
I I just don't think it quite holds up
that's our show we had a lot more to get
to but unfortunately you know you know
how this happens I'll see you tomorrow
get your mail bad questions in for
Thursday I am going to be traveling by
the way I'm going to be giving a speech
at the University of Missouri Kansas
City so I think I think we'll be in
studio but I'll be flying out for that
tomorrow
check it out I'm hoping will stream it
but if you're in Kansas City come by and
say hello
in the meantime I'm Michael Knowles this
is the Michael Nolt show see you
tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Robert Sterling executive producer
Jeremy Moore senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Dani D'Amico
audio is mixed by Dylan case hair and
makeup is by Jessa of era production
assistant Nick Shyam the Michael Noel's
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19 today on the
Ben Shapiro show the media and Democrats
Lander President Trump over immigration
and an NBA player talks about his white
privilege that's today on the Ben
Shapiro show